with the sound of drums and prayer songs
the remains of nine
sikangu oyate lakota children returned
home to their native land
[Music]
their story is a long and painful one
stretching back over 140 years
there's going to be a lot of sadness
here today beginning in 1879
native children from the lakota and
other tribes
were sent to government-run boarding
schools
the first group embarked on steamships
from this point on the missouri river
headed for a government school in
faraway carlisle pennsylvania
a lot of the kids were probably this was
the last place they saw their parents
they bought them here and got on the
boat tens of thousands of native
children
entered boarding schools the project was
meant to assimilate
to destroy native language culture and
religion
and to turn the young people into model
christian americans
but many did not survive the school's
harsh regime
of maltreatment neglect and disease
for decades the lakota children lay
buried in carlisle's cemetery
but they were never forgotten after
years of
effort to properly identify the remains
and then carefully exhume them
children including little hawk hollow
horn bear
strikes first swift bear and others
who left so long ago are surrounded by
their people once more
that's what we want for those kids for
them to come home
does it make you feel emotional yeah
kind of hurts you know but i'm really
happy
young lakota reflect on the hardships
their relatives endured
i would have been full of terror i would
have been full of
i would expect nothing but death
to be honest it's almost a nauseating
feeling to
to realize what these kids been through
the children's remains were placed on
the ground inside a specially
constructed tepee
there surrounded by relatives and
religious leaders
they were welcomed home in a private
prayer ceremony
later the entire community gathered as
the remains were laid out
wrapped in buffalo hides and surrounded
by sacred sage
people prayed long into the night the
homecoming is an event of enormous
emotional and spiritual
importance to his people says organizer
russell eaglebear
there's a re-awakening of our people
and that's important you know we need to
we can't be living in grief all the time
and on the following day the children
were laid to rest
in the local cemetery home at last in
the land
where they belong rob reynolds al
jazeera
mission south dakota